Speaker 1: I've got whacked out video of Ron
DeSantis in Japan.
Shake, but shaking and smiling.
I don't know if someone told him, You've got
to look cheerful and this is how he did it.
But the guy's personality really leaves a
little something to be desired.
Ron DeSantis was asked upon, I guess, landing
in Japan, what's the deal with like, you're
losing every poll to Trump, which is true.
And DeSantis is visibly shaking and it's very
strange.
I don't believe this is a medical event, but
people are studying this like the Zapruder
film, suggesting it's a deepfake, but it is
all too real.
Look at this governor.
Speaker 5: And show you falling behind a Trump
and his eyes on that guy.
I'm not I'm not a candidate.
So we'll see if if and when that changes.
Speaker 1: Yeah, really weird stuff.
I'm going to play it for you once more.
And it it is strange.
Strange stuff.
Speaker 5: Anger at Trump.
Any thoughts on it, guys?
I'm not I'm not a candidate.
So we'll see if if and when that changes.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Note, by the way, there is no belief that
this is a medical event.
Ron DeSantis doesn't have tardive dyskinesia
or any of these things.
We're not making fun of medical conditions.
It seems as though this is how he's been coached,
to be upbeat, to shake and smile like a horror
clown, like from a scary movie.
I don't think this guy has what it takes.
The latest polling continues to show weak
numbers for desanctis.
Little bit of a pop up, but basically still
between 23 and 24.
The green line at the bottom of your screen
is DeSantis.
The purple line at the top is Trump.
Trump still between 52 and 53.
DeSantis or Desanctis or the sanctimonious
between 23 and 24.
And this 50% number is a very important thing.
If you're Ron DeSantis and you're thinking
about Do I run?
Do I not run?
If Trump already has 53%.
You could get all of the non-Trump vote over
to yourself and you still wouldn't have enough,
right?
You could pick up Pence's four and Haley's
four and Tim Scott's 1.6 and Ramaswamy is
1.4.
You could get all of that and you'd still
only have 47.
So, you know, there is a period of six weeks
ago, I would have said DeSantis isn't going
to be able to get away from running.
He's going to run.
I'm not so sure now.
I'm not so sure.
It may actually not make sense for him to
get involved in this.
And if that's the case, Trump runs away with
this thing.
The argument for DeSantis to get involved
would be even if Trump already has 50%, you
need to be there visible and holding 25%.
In case Trump gets arrested again.
In case Trump gets indicted again, in case
it becomes clear Trump can't possibly run
a campaign amidst the chaos of one, two or
three different indictments.
You need to be there with 25% to then pick
up some of Trump's support if and when it
becomes clear Trump simply can't do this.
That's the best argument for DeSantis, because
the numbers right now show a DeSantis that
can't possibly win.